there you're watching the press preview
our first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive so it's time to see
what's making the headlines with the
daily mails consultant editor andrew
pearce and the daily mirrors associate
editor kevin mcguire so a very good
evening nice to see you both and you
will be with us up until around midnight
so um
we'll speak to you in just a moment uh
first though let's uh check in on what's
on the front pages for tomorrow morning
and the end of a six-year ordeal for the
british iranian hostage
the metro has the headline nazanin jet's
home
it's the guardian's lead story as well
picturing nazanin there on the plane
the daily telegraph quotes her husband's
words to their young daughter mummy
really is coming home
the daily mail does something similar
with mummy's home at last
and the mirror puts it home for a nice
cuppa
the express two pictures nazanin on the
cover with the headline the smile that
says i'm free
the financial times meanwhile has word
of apparent progress in talks between
ukraine and russia aimed at achieving
peace
while the star says that over a million
and a half pounds has been raised to put
vladimir putin on a rocket and shoot him
into space
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the programme you can check out all
those front pages for yourself of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
and so here with me andrew pierce and
kevin mcguire um
good to see you both on an evening where
there is some good news um on many of
the front pages andrew really seeing
these pictures across the papers you
picked out the daily mail your own paper
to start with of nazanin zagari
ratcliffe sitting on a plane
taking her away from iran after six
years in detention and after
a tense 24 hours as well um is such a
pleasure isn't it to see a sign of pure
positivity amidst all the gloom of
recent news
yeah and it's a lovely photograph of her
look how she's smiling because she's
feeling liberated she knows she's almost
she's almost there now but the the
mummy's home at last is a very human
touch because it must have been apart
from being incarcerated in that prison
for five years she then was in in under
effect of house arrest in her parents
home
not to be able to see her daughter
i mean her daughter was two i think when
she got locked up
and um
she's going to be reunited it's going to
be a very emotional reunion isn't it and
um and it's going to be very difficult
for the daughter daughter to because she
hardly knows our mum now um she's kept
in touch on telephone conversations and
and uh through through through the the
phone but um
oh to be a fly on the wall for when they
are reunited and richard
is the dad he's a most fantastic guy
kevin and i've met him many many times
in various tv studios he's been the most
articulate advocate for his wife uh and
he's been heroic because he's had to
combine his job with being a single
parent too with keeping up the pressure
on the government which also included
last year if you remember a three-week
hunger strike he is a remarkable man and
um
and i i i it's just fabulous to think
how
excited he must be now to know he's
getting his family back
absolutely and at the front of the daily
telegraph as well that same picture of
nazanin
that's her on the flight from muscat she
she went to oman first of all
before she she's due to land in the next
few hours their headline as well mommy
really is coming home reflecting richard
ratcliffe's
words at kevin and a lot of questions
today
people welcoming the news but also
asking why it's taken so long
how much difference do you think that
richard ratcliffe himself has made to
galvanizing the government and
bringing together some kind of deal
i think a huge amount in keeping the
case in the public eye define foreign
office advice which was essentially
keep quiet uh keep out of sight don't do
anything we will deal with it and he he
knew that would have just ended uh
absolutely no way and richard radcliffe
as uh andrew said is just a remarkable
guy absolutely brilliant campaigner
saw him on his hunger strike in in
whitehall when he was outside the
iranian embassy at countless times
absolutely tireless uh as were the
family of anusha shuri who was also
coming home uh
they're gonna be reunited uh too but
you've you've gotta think how did it go
on for so long how
how were mistakes made along the line
and and jeremy hunt who was a foreign
secretary it's happened on a liz trust
as a
watch um fortunately in one way but also
she deserves credit as as tulip sadiq
the labour mp who represents the uh the
radcliffs uh who has been brilliant
herself uh acknowledged uh trusses uh
role in making direct contact with the
iranians the foreign minister trying to
reset relations after there was a new
government about six months ago in
tehran but
you know jeremy hunt my foreign
secretary he said back uh you know four
years back that you could see
immediately the link with britain's
unpaid debt the near 400 million pounds
from the undelivered tanks going back to
the end of the charles ring in the in
the 1970s and why did we not get there
quicker because
nazim sagari ratcliffe yeah it's relief
as uh andrew said beaming freedom but
she's had six years of absolute hell and
i remember the moment she sent gabriella
home because of course her daughter was
with her when she was arrested at tehran
airport she'd taken her to see her her
parents
and
she sent she sent her back to britain
because originally she was with her
parents and would visit her in jail but
then she took the decision get her a
safety um but that from for a mother
must have been an almighty wrench
because of course you always want to do
what's best for your child but you also
want to keep them close uh and to send
gabrielle who's now seven uh ahead to
london
she must have been counting the days for
years
yeah
absolutely and let's take a look at the
um guardians front page as well
shall we andrew um zagari radcliff
released after six years in iran jail
but as kevin was saying that we should
remember that anusha ashuri also on that
flight arrested in
2017 also accused of spying um also
released on that same flight back too
but the guardian also reminds us that
there is also a third but it says jewel
national here i think they're
tri-national i think they have british
iranian and american nationality andrew
don't they uh released from prison but
not released from iran
no and and and they're feeling um while
all attention naturally is focused on
nazarene because she's a mom she's a
woman uh
that he has been overlooked and
neglected and uh
and it's hard not to to agree with that
they must be well then the family of him
will be feeling thrilled that nazanin
and the other guy are on their way back
it must be very frustrating that while
he's out of prison he's still in iran
and they'll want to get him home as
quickly as possible now maybe
liz trust has broke had this
breakthrough with her uh
foreign minister counterpart in iran
perhaps she can uh now secure that one
too i think she's done well actually um
it's easy to say that um
tulips had the local mp's been very good
but there's no doubt liz trust when she
became foreign minister she made nazanin
a priority it was one of the first
things she did on her first day as
foreign secretary she really really
wanted to get it sorted and effectively
what we've done we've paid a ransom now
the government will never admit that
because we don't pay ransoms for
hostages but we have paid a ransom
because nazim was kidnapped she was
killed kidnapped by the iranian state on
trump-type charges and we paid a ransom
and got her out and i suspect that was
the part of the hold up the governor did
not want to be seen to be paying her
answer do you think it's fair to
characterize it like that kevin i mean
liz trust was at pains to stress that
this was not money that was going in in
cash in any way it was going into in in
the form of humanitarian aid it wasn't
going to be a problem as far as
sanctions or money laundering
regulations were concerned they'd
obviously
gone to some effort to make sure that
the the payment was made in an
appropriate way
yeah i think i think that's just a bit
of cover really once it's there they can
spend on whatever they they like but the
reason i would say is not a
a ransom although i agree
that they were held hostage and it was
clearly linked to the the 400 million
near 400 million is because it was a
debt it was a debt that uh that britain
should have repaid many years earlier we
owed the money uh jeremy hunt has
stressed that but
you've really got to feel sorry for the
family and uh murad tabaz himself
because he's born in hammersmith in in
in london but as you say he is a
a tri-national he also has a u.s
citizenship and so the iranians see him
as an american and separate to the deal
with uh britain and reading in the
guardian patrick winter who covers
foreign affairs for them is very well
informed and very very thoughtful and
measured uh says the foreign office
actually tried to include murad tabaz in
the deal but they couldn't get anywhere
so in the end they've got the two out
but i'm sure they'll be very very heavy
hearts
on that there is somebody else there who
has been left behind yeah released from
jail um
at least we know that and obviously
everyone are keeping their fingers
crossed for him too
um let's move on to the situation in
ukraine we've only got a few minutes
left and obviously it's still a huge um
area of concern the front of the
financial times andre has an interesting
article doesn't it um which talks about
a possible plan that will could form a
basis for for peace talks at the moment
so what does it tell us
well
i mean it's it's it's a long way off i
think but i mean at least both sides are
talking and it's all about um the
carver of territory now um the the idea
being that um putin get gives up the
territory he's encroached on gained
during this war and probably just keeps
the the the crimean the stuff he annexed
in 2014
uh and and of course this will all be
linked to
ukraine giving up its commitment its
wish to join nato but i know but is
putin really going to give up the
territory that he's he's lost thousands
of people uh uh fighting over i don't
know but that's what it's all about at
the moment where they are talking and
that's got to be encouraging uh and i'm
sure zelensky that extraordinary
inspiring ukrainian president will want
to deal if he can do one
and kevin that talking does continue but
so do the bombs too the front of the
telegraph um covers this
hideous
story the reports that russia has bombed
a theater where the suggestion is
amongst local ukrainians that um
around a thousand people could have been
sheltering
no absolutely if if the talks of a hope
this is the horror and horror continuing
uh across much of ukraine and look on
that theater as you say uh the figures
seem to vary from 1000 to
1200 families mainly children sheltering
there written on the building in russian
that it was uh housing children
you dread to think now what's going to
follow um if if it has been here and it
looks like it it has because we know
this time last week we were discussing
the hospital
and the
what had happened there and of course
was that picture of the
very pregnant woman being carried out on
a stretcher and then you learned later
she and the baby both died no look these
these are war crimes unquestionably now
joe biden the u.s president said putin
was a was a war criminal putin from the
kremlin seemed to got rather upset about
that well what else can you call
bombing and shelling
a very urban areas whether it whether
it's hospitals theaters houses or
whatever or shooting people in
a bread uh queue i mean this is just
utterly utterly horrific absolutely well
andrew and kevin were out of time for
this particular section but you are
staying with us as i say until just
before midnight so i will see you again
at the top of the hour at 11 for the
moment though thank you